la rue saint-jean à québec pratiquement
vide
la grande allée une autre rue fantôme
des villes désertes le soir c'est ce
qu'on verra partout au québec pendant un
mois entre 20h et 5h du matin un
couvre-feu forcera les québécois à
rester chez eux à partir de samedi
jusqu'au 8 février
on est obligé aujourd'hui d'annoncer un
espèce de traitement choc pour réduire
en trop le nombre de visites dans les
maisons
avec cette mesure coup de poing françois
legault espère que les québécois à
saisir l'ampleur de la situation
on est actuellement pour le prochain
mois au pire de la bataille c'est
maintenant qu'il faut réduire la
contagion donc je compte sur tous les
québécois
non seulement la pause forcée des
commerces non essentiels se poursuit
mais en plus les épiceries et les
dépanneurs fermeront plus tôt à 19h30
seules les pharmacies et les stations
service conserve l'horaire habituel
aussi les restaurants pourront continuer
la livraison il sera permis de sortir
uniquement pour les soins de santé pour
des raisons humanitaires ou pour du
travail essentiel sous peine de recevoir
une amende variant 2000 à 6000 $ pour
moi c'est la priorité
l'école on doit cela à nos jeunes si le
gouvernement envisageait de reporter le
retour en classe le tollé provoqué par
les pédiatres et le professeur a eu un
impact
les élèves du primaire reviendront à
l'école comme prévu lundi prochain
seuls les enfants des travailleurs
essentiel auront droit aux services de
garde scolaire
on va demander aux enfants de porter un
masque ou un couvre le visage de rezé
dans les corridors
puis les élèves de 5e et 6e année de
porter un coup au visage en classe au
secondaire le retour est reportée d'une
semaine seulement au 18 janvier
les élèves devront tout supporter un
couvre visage en classe 2 masque de
procédure par jour leur seront
distribués ainsi qu'aux enseignants les
bibliothèques municipales seront
accessibles à ceux qui n'ont pas d'accès
internet les prochains mois vous êtes
le critique on est comme dans une course
contre la montre
les cpe restent ouverts le télétravail
demeure obligatoire les activités
extérieures sont permises mais
uniquement en bulle familiale
les stations de ski peuvent maintenir
leur activité le jour seulement on parle
vraiment de sauver des vies et de sauver
notre système de santé une personne
seule pourra recevoir la visite d'une
seule autre personne
les lieux de culte ferme de nouveau les
funérailles sont limitées à 10 personnes
sensibles aux critiques concernant la
liste des produits essentiels le
gouvernement permettra maintenant une
collecte à la porte pour tout autre type
d'achat la construction et le secteur
manufacturier sont tenus de fonctionner
au strict minimum en plein déficit
record de 15 milliards de dollars
l'économie du québec subira un autre
grand coup mais c'est le fort prix à
payer en attendant les résultats
la vaccination ici véronique prince
radio canada québec